welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's keynote presentation
clinical lab 2.0 laboratories can thrive
in a value-based care system it is
presented by Michael Crossy MD PhD the
chief executive officer and chief
medical officer for tricor reference
laboratories my name is Judy O'Rourke
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots laberd's is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before we begin I would like to
remind everyone this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
and type your questions into the
drop-down box our speaker will respond
to your questions via email following
the presentation if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the ask a question box
to let us know that you're experiencing
a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
in the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits and now
about further ado please join me in
welcoming dr. cross II I will now turn
the presentation over to them thank you
I I really appreciate the offer to to be
a speaker today I hope to present some
ideas and some challenges for the
clinical labs in the United States
specifically on really changing our
place in the medical delivery system and
the vernacular I'm going to use is
clinical lab 2.0 as the target of where
we want to be so so for today I'd like
to talk about how laboratories can not
just survive but actually thrive in a
value-based care system let me
for the objectives the establishing
value and I purposely put that in quotes
because value is in the eye of the
beholder or in our case the payer and
the payer is different in different
situations so when we talk about value I
really want you to keep in mind who is
it you're talking about it's not just
one size fits all secondly and very
importantly is discuss how the
laboratory data not just the results but
actually the aggregate data that we
produce can affect clinical outcomes
both for patients and populations and
that's really a crux issue if you're
talking about value and you're gonna
have to exploit that in one way or
another to really bring the laboratory
up to parity with our other clinical
colleagues and finally I want to push
and really this is this is probably the
most important thing is lab leadership
role and dealing discussing with you
know non traditional clinical
stakeholders who who else do we impact
with our again not just our results but
our aggregate data so with those three I
hope to frame a discussion and and maybe
Jabar a few ideas or dispel a couple of
myths that we've entrenched ourselves in
over the last 50 years of clinical lab
medicine so let me let me start tricor
reference laboratories we service
virtually all of New Mexico we have
multiple clinical specialties we have
their 12 1910 offered on the menu we
resulted 14 million tests last year we
cover about 60% of the clinical lab work
here in New Mexico and 98% of it is
in our laboratories with 1300 employees
our careers move specimens all around
the state we have draw sites all over
New Mexico 50 plus pathologists working
in various AP NCP of roles both from the
University from Presbyterian and
Lovelace three different pathology
groups we interact with regularly and we
have very high patient satisfaction with
is a big focus for tricor fifteen
different hospitals in the system around
the state so that's that's sort of the
literally and figuratively that lay of
the land that that I'm speaking from we
are one of the first cap 15 189
accredited laboratory system so that
means a procedure and Tucumcari is the
same procedure in Socorro or here in
Albuquerque at the clinical laboratory
bench so that's kind of important
because that that leveled and normalized
a lot of the data that we use when we're
doing aggregate data I know all of you
have heard in probably every talk you've
ever gone to or at least every seminar
panel discussion that the laboratory
medicine you know affects has a role in
drives 70 percent of clinical decisions
and I I want to dispel that and I want
laboratorians to quit using that it's
not true it's never been actually
completely validated the source is
somewhat hearsay honestly but I want to
challenge you that if you're going to
say that and you're going to believe it
the you also have to concede through
very good validated studies that waste
consumes about 30 percent of US
healthcare dollars so if you just do the
math
you're gonna say 70% of clinical
decisions come from the laboratory and
the laboratory has to own 21 percent of
healthcare waste so you can't have it
both ways if you're gonna say you're
that important then one of the things
you have to do is use that influence to
drive out waste so I'd throw this out as
a challenge no matter who the
stakeholders are waste has zero value
and if the laboratory is that important
one of the things we really need to be
focusing on is reducing waste not just
within our laboratory walls but outside
our laboratory walls and I and I hope
that shows some examples of how we can
influence that and the second challenge
is we talk a lot about innovation and in
in fact when we say we're going from lab
1.0 to lab 2.0 and it's very innovative
you have to be willing to accept that
innovation requires disruption now in a
fee-for-service world waste is often
rewarded in a value-based purchasing
world efficiency is what's rewarded so
there they're really two ends of a very
very long spectrum and it's okay to
survive in one fee-for-service world if
everybody's in value-based purchasing
you know it's a level playing field the
real danger is getting from that point A
to point B and I would say point B is
coming whether you like it or not so you
have to gear yourself toward value-based
purchasing which means driving
efficiency not just in the lab but in
our whole clinical medical enterprise
and labs have to be willing to
cannibalize themselves or parts of their
business in order to move from a
fee-for-service world to a value-based
purchasing world now the risk for
laboratories the biggest risk is to wait
is to be passive is to be the guys in
the basement
that are just going to wait for the
c-suite to tell them what to do next or
how much of their budgets going to get
cut next year that that is an incredibly
risky posture and I wouldn't recommend
it to anybody along with that we can't
do it alone the laboratory can only do
so much so what I would challenge my
laboratory colleagues to do is to work
very diligently on partnerships the
laboratory has an amazing influence with
our clinical colleagues with our
pharmacy colleagues nursing colleagues
we affect all of their workflows and
work streams so the challenge isn't to
say we're gonna come up with a dashboard
out of the laboratory and suddenly drive
all the waste out of Medicine that's
just not going to happen
we can do it but we have to do it with
partners so I would challenge you to
within your own institutions within your
own health systems you know you really
need to start looking for those key
partnerships and literally people that
you can work with to drive waste out of
your system so partnership and do not
remain passive would be the two biggest
challenges I would put out there to make
it in a value-based world one of the
things that just to set the frame of
what we're all talking about and I'm
sure everybody has heard one meeting or
another in the last year about lab 1.0
so that that vernacular is the past lab
1.0 is a value-based system it's
transactional it's very sample centric
it's a fee-for-service world we're
really talking about cost per unit and
you know we're not we're not talking
about care coordination we're not really
getting out of the laboratory at all
it's very lab centered in a complicated
health environment that means the lab is
just operating in its
we do a lot of Lean Six Sigma we tighten
up our game in the lab we you know make
sure we don't have any waste but the
waste we're talking about was very lab
centric and so on the graph at the top
of this slide we that's where we spent
most of our time we're really we were
hyper focused on the analytical
sensitivity and specificity of our tests
we're very enamored with the new tests
of one sort or another whether it's
molecular or proteomics or metabolomics
we're really looking at what we do in
the laboratory as opposed to the black
line which is the pre analytical
ordering the right test helping our
clinicians order the right tests and
then the post analytical on the right
side there which is did they interpret
that test correctly was it easy to
interpret did we do we even produce a
result that was actionable so those are
the two differences you know the 1.0 is
really based in the laboratory 2.0 is
going to force us out of the laboratory
to prove our value and that's with a
patient-centered approach not a sample
centric approach we'll be under a
bundled payment structure which means
hospitals healthcare systems a cos large
integrated systems are going to get a
bundled payment and the laboratory is
going to have to prove that they're
worth some part of that PI and and and
get our reimbursement from our own
health system as opposed directly from a
payer or or a outside client and there
are - we have to elevate from a
transactional of one order one test can
we aggregate things at a cost per
covered lives now we're talking about a
population-based and again if we have
all that data how can we aggravate it
for a health plan or a clinic or an ACO
to help them take better care of not
just a patient but a population of
patients
so forth on that lab 2.0 is diagnostic
optimization - are we ordering tests
that are appropriate are we helping
clinicians order the right tests so that
care is coordinated and I'll talk a lot
more about that in a few slides upcoming
and again on the post analytical side of
things is the test and the result
actionable is the interpretation easy to
read is that are we giving them actually
information instead of just data and
hoping they interpret it the way it
should be interpreted but aggregation of
data is going to be very key in a
value-based system where you're talking
about populations in addition to just
the patient aggregating data for a
patient on a longitudinal record
aggregating data on a small population
of a clinic aggregating large sets of
data for a entire health plan and I
would argue all of us have heard about
the Triple Aim you know the focus coming
out of the Institute of Medicine is that
America really has three major issues in
healthcare access to care cost and
quality and I would tell my laboratory
colleagues that that is where we need to
focus that that Triple Aim is not going
to go away and it actually gives us the
focus of saying if I think this is
valuable how does it play into this
Triple Aim as a measuring stick for
value-based payments that's not just
about our clinical colleagues
that's about us in the laboratory what
are we doing on access patient access as
well as access to data across the system
Hospital outreach point of care I mean
we're the focal point of a lot of that
data and are we making that data easy to
access wherever it came in to our system
for any given patient and then cost
control again this is not
cost for tests we do a lot with lean and
Six Sigma to drive down our unit cost as
a hospital but the more important thing
is what's the cost for covered lives
what's the cost for episode of care
what's the cost for a population of
patients that are underneath a certain
plan or a planned derivative those are
the kind of costs that that bring it to
a higher level and that's much more
valuable than a cost per test and third
and absolutely always been the focus of
the laboratory is quality quality I
think all of us in a accredited
laboratory have very high standards with
our proficiency testing the
standardization the FDA review of the
tests that we perform even our LDT tests
that are very stringently validated and
control quality is the laboratories
claim to fame we are probably the
leaders in that in our own silo of
medicine but outside the silo of
medicine quality I think we could have a
great impact on what what are we doing
to help the quality of a patient's care
and again that would be a quick example
would be how are we helping physicians
order the right tests as opposed to
guessing what what the right test is and
again at the other end of the spectrum
is the population what are we doing for
the quality of a population that's being
taken care of by a specific group or a
clinic um so if I don't think there
would be any reason to think that the
Triple Aim is going to go away so I
would offer that you should use it to
really examine where do you add value as
a laboratory and
in your system to help the greater
Enterprise achieve the Triple Aim so
let's talk about access
a little bit data laboratory data can be
generated in multiple multiple different
ways here's a map of New Mexico as an
example we have hospitals draw sites and
providers you know scattered all over
the state if you think about a patient
in rural New Mexico who has an abnormal
laboratory result how do they connect
into the myriad of hospitals we have
clinics we have independent providers we
have those are really going to be
difficult to connect but the laboratory
is the focus of that we are the hub of
this crazy hub-and-spoke system so we
know that this patient who who has an
abnormal result and is continuing with
an abnormal result possibly getting
worse needs to see a specific provider
that might not even be in their zip code
but is across the state in in with the
health plan that's the this the center
of the payment system how can we get
that patient to the care they need using
not just the health system like the
bricks and mortar hospitals and clinics
but the health system that includes the
health plan that that patient is being
taken care of and the care coordination
that might come out of that health plan
or it might come out of the clinic they
derived from so that was a complicated
way of saying it I have a I have a very
simplified real-world example of where
we actually did that but but if you're
gonna say that the clinical labs guides
significant value for the patient it's
going to be more than giving accurate
results you're gonna have to affect not
just the result to the provider you're
gonna have to
care coordination of that patient if you
really want to have value and there's a
an interesting analog to that is we're
also also in the laboratory very
enamored of the tests we do you know
they're they're the most accurate
they're the most state-of-the-art
they're the coolest new shiny object
that we're offering but if it doesn't
really affect that patients care in a
significant way we're gonna have to
really think about how we offer and what
we offer on our menus so that that's
gonna be a challenge because when you
stay in your laboratory silo you want to
focus on the test when you get out of
the laboratory and into the enterprise
you want to focus on how did that test
actually affect a patient's care this
was something I pulled out of the dark
report and it's a very very troubling
thing to me and I wanted to call it out
and it's where laboratories large health
systems are saying you know that whole
outpatient stuff and outreach is really
problematic and hard to do well and hard
to sustain and you know the
reimbursement is dropping under Pama you
know so lab outreach is is really not
our core business we want to hunker down
and and focus on our inpatient business
and I think this is a wrong approach
because if if you follow my line of
thought controlling the data producing
the data accessing the data and
aggregating the data is the value of the
laboratory as soon as you stop
collecting data because it's too hard on
the outpatient side or there's you know
too many different hospitals and it's
easier to leave them in silos instead of
aggregating that data on a patient's
longitudinal record you're really
decrease
the value in a very significant way
you've now blinded yourself to a
significant amount of data that a
patient follows our patient is apprised
with on a regular basis and so you're
you're becoming blind to that and that
means you can't contribute to it I'll
have an example of that in a minute so
again the power of the laboratory let's
let's talk about cost
so there's access and again I hope
access I'm talking I convinced you that
access is as much about access to data
as patients access to a clinic when it
comes to cost if you look at the
Medicare breakdown basically you know
50% of the patients are stage one their
patients with minimal disease not not
really accessing the system on a regular
basis not costing the system a lot
Stage two which is about 40 percent
their patients that have clinically
significant chronic disease but they're
still kind of in the mid-range the high
utilizers Stage three is really only ten
percent of patients but they have
advanced disease and end-stage disease
on 18 to 24 months of of life now you
look at the the spend on that and it's
completely reversed that large
population that doesn't access the
system is only costing 5% the middle
group is costing 31% but that that
little 10% at the tip is costing 64
percent of the cost so the the whole
point of the Triple Aim is how do we
intervene early to keep that last 10%
from costing such an astronomical 64
percent of the total spend for the
Medicare population spent and that's
difficult that's not an easy challenge I
think for us though is if weakens
thinking and our enterprises and our
large integrated health systems with
health plans is probably in well care
how can we keep that population healthy
and the labs can play a big part in that
labs can be a huge tool for engaging
patients in their own health care I
believe and in the management once they
have diseases that middle group how can
we keep them from progressing stays from
progressing from stage one and to
chronic renal disease to stage three or
four and requiring dialysis how can we
provide data to keep that progression
down so that's that's an area where I
think laboratory uns have to think
differently about their contribution to
the value of the lab results that we
produce we can do a lot more in the
health and wellness side and the
management one of the things you should
think about I think the laboratory
should think about is instead of
producing a laboratory result we have
been able to show and I'll show an
example of this in a few minutes of not
only what did we resolve for any given
patient but what we didn't resolve so I
think when you're thinking about that
middle group that stage two forty
percent of Medicare patients we can tell
physicians not only what we did on a
diabetic say we did an a1c but we should
also be able to tell them that we
haven't done an a1c in six to nine
months on that patient that patients
gone dark so now I'm talking about value
to a health plan of revealing not just
what you did but it's actually more
valuable in some cases to tell them what
you didn't do now that's kind of a
interesting other side of the coin for
laboratories to start thinking about how
can they produce a spreadsheet that
shows not only what they did for a given
set of patients but what did they didn't
do who didn't
for that lab draw who didn't get it
collected or who it didn't get ordered
so that that's an interesting way to
think about that middle group when
you're managing disease patients the
results are almost as important as the
lack of results so so again let's let's
look at this graph this is this is lab
1.0 is transactional here's a lab result
in the middle of the screen it's it's
very accurate I you know I'm very
confident that you know I could put
error bars around that and and assure a
physician that it's you know plus or
minus two percent and that's lab point
one very transactional very test focused
so let's call that a serum creatinine
it's one point one okay like I said it's
a very good accurate creatinine I spent
a lot of time validating the test its
harmonized across my whole enterprise so
the cracking in one place is the same as
if cracking the other that's not an easy
thing to do
I mean lab 1.0 is not easy to have a
high-quality rock-solid laboratory with
accurate results that physicians never
question is not easy but it's also lab
1.0 you don't get paid anymore for the
absolutely accurate cracking compared to
one that might not be but that's what
we've all strived for and that's what
we've all strived for in the last twenty
years that's the basis of what we're
building on you you actually have to
have an incredibly accurate lab to go
from lab 1.0 to lab 2.0 but now let's
take that what I know about this patient
because of my longitudinal record you
know I can look at outpatient those two
let's say those two black dots in the
lower left hand corner or previous serum
creatinine taken on an outpatient draw
now the serum creatinine in the middle
is you know what I'm looking at on an
inpatient draw
over the next few days I see two more
creatinine's that are rising so that's
now become incredibly valuable
information now now you're talking about
lab 1.5 say because I'm looking at not
just the creatinine I produced but I'm
comparing that patient's creatinine with
that patient's previous creatinine and
that patients next subsequent draws they
it's pretty clear you're seeing a trend
here that could be you know significant
for that patient and I put the the air
those aren't error bars I put up there I
put that as an example of normal range
so just from for the clinical
pathologists in the room you can see
that those outpatient draws you know
that was already a significant increase
before that first read a serum
creatinine from an inpatient draw so the
patient was already headed into some
renal insufficiency sick and they hadn't
actually left the error bars or the
normal range sorry so now to take that
and make it a lab 2.0 I would argue that
you take that serum creatinine now with
the metadata you have from all your
laboratory orders from outpatient and
inpatient even you're looking at a
population where you can take that serum
creatinine and you add that there high
risk because of their age they also have
comorbid icd-10 results or icd-10 codes
coming over the same state they have
diabetes and hypertension so now you've
moved that patient from just a lab
result of what was a serum creatinine to
a high risk patient because of not only
the result but because of data that you
combined that puts them at a high risk
for a potential bad outcome in this
hospitalization so really that's the
difference where we we can use much more
data than we're normally used to
so I'll try to tie everything into one
example that we've done here in New
Mexico that it shows I believe the power
of the laboratory dealing with different
partners dealing with not only the data
we produce but identifying data that we
didn't have it should have been done and
then reporting that result in a post
analytical phase to folks that could
really action on it and the example is
prenatal care here in New Mexico New
Mexico is a fairly rural state but 72%
of New Mexico's birth fall under our
Medicaid funded programs and 20% when we
looked at the data we would say 20% of
New Mexico's births receive prenatal
care in the second trimester that's way
too many that are receiving care in the
second trimester instead of the first
and then eight-point-five received no
prenatal care they basically came in at
time of delivery without any history so
you can imagine the the risk of those
births so 3% about received intermediate
care I'd say but but still inadequate
now if you look at the graph on the
right the cost of newborns with
complications is upwards to $13,000 13
to 14 and fiscal year of 10 versus
fiscal year 10 this this is not
laboratory data this actually came out
from from the New Mexico Senate Finance
Committee so this was already being
discussed up at the Senate Finance
Committee about how to control Medicaid
cost and you can see why 13 $14,000 per
delivery versus an uncomplicated newborn
delivery of 800 that's a that's a big
impact to the state so that kind of
frames the the scale of the problem
and then you look at the background in
the labs role in prenatal care
well identifying and monitoring of
potential moderates mothers we have
first trimester care issues second
trimester care issues on third trimester
care issues the blood banking stuff they
should go on the infectious disease
testing that should go on across all
three trimesters there's a first
trimester serum screen second trimester
screen Group B Strep within the third
trimester gestational diabetes testing
it should go on in the second trimester
and then identifying and monitoring
prenatal risks so again using ancillary
data that we have because it comes over
with the lab tests of age possible
previous diagnosis of diabetes or other
things urinary tract infections can be a
high risk for some folks and and we're
doing the that testing should we combine
it with that prenatal longitudinal
record yeah absolutely we need to pull
that in and make sure if people are
aware that that patient had a urinary
tract infection it might not be
something that was diagnosed with their
ob/gyn it might have been something that
they went to an urgent care for but
since we're at the central laboratory we
can connect those dots and then abnormal
prenatal screening needs to be dealt
with so identifying a birth you know
when we see newborn screening come in we
can we can also use that data where we
can alert a health plan or a Medicaid
provider of a birth that should have the
newborn screening and tie that back to
the prenatal care actually so the way we
did this in this example this this isn't
a hypothetical this is actually
something we did I want to be clear
about that we received an eligibility
file from a large health plan we matched
that eligibility file with try cores
patient repository focusing specific
they on Medicaid beneficiaries and then
we used our our internal IT and
analytics system to look at health
conditions and looked produced targeted
interventions that means the member file
we got from the payer we key members
were identified and matched successful
matches were pulled out and analyzed
with our targeted intervention module
which is looking at the standard of care
from the American College of obstetrics
and gynecology so we could say for these
women this is what we've done this is
how far along they've done this is their
care gaps and then the results were
pushed back to the managed care
organization for care or coordination
and we did this on a weekly basis for
seven months so let me give an example
here of again this this wasn't this this
isn't made up this was an actual patient
23 year-old female in rural New Mexico
she had access to Albuquerque PD which
is where the pregnancy test was
performed later she received a prenatal
workup with a nurse midwife in several
months later she also accessed a needy
and at a urinary-tract diagnosed later
toward nine months you had a baby girl
that had some complications and was
admitted to the neonatal intensive care
unit was there for a number of days
weeks and a discharge cost to that
system or to that health plan was about
seven hundred and eighty nine thousand
dollars similar thing another twenty
three-year-old female and urban New
Mexican urban New Mexico said the first
was female second was a urban I'm sorry
the first was a rural and the second is
an urban example again and
our diagnosis of pregnancy this one
actually had a care manager coordinated
OBGYN
their care so the woman did get into
care from an OBGYN office they received
all the prenatals screens a baby boy was
born a little postdates at 40 weeks and
the baby and mom were discharged into
care and that was about a $2,200
pregnancy so massive massive difference
in cost of care simply because that
first example was uncoordinated so let
me give you a second example a 30 year
old female so she's access a family
practice with a diagnosis of pregnancy
receives this one received monthly drug
monitoring that we were performing here
in the lab to baby girl was admitted to
the NICU
discharged from the ICU and again 996
thousand dollars is incredibly expensive
pregnancy kind of age-matched example to
a 27 year old female initial prenatal
screen we called identified a care
manager to help plan to coordinate care
patient was brought in to be followed by
a high-risk OB GYN group the baby was
born at 39 weeks the mom and the baby
were discharged that was you know three
thousand dollar pregnancy again you're
talking orders of magnitude of impact to
the health system the the cost of that
of those pregnancies are taken out of
the medicaid fund which means those
funds aren't there for other things so
you know this cost differential is
probably the highest value a laboratory
I can deliver way beyond the testing for
cell-free DNA or prenatal testing or
even Group B testing so aggregating
information and pushing it to care
coordinators for them to action on it
was a much much higher value than the
actual laboratory tests themselves but
it required getting out of the
laboratory they required partnering with
a health plan and care coordination and
the ob/gyn departments that are to
sponsor institutions so again lab 1.0 is
about lab and treating physicians very
transactional doctors order tests lab
produced result results we assume
they're doing all the right things
I can tell you that looking at providers
and looking at physician burnout over
the last few years
providers are completely overwhelmed
they are begging us for health and care
coordination in picking the right tests
this lab point 1.0 relationship with
just lab 2 providers won't won't stand
going forward in the next three to five
years we're gonna have to do better so
what I propose is lab leadership 2.0
leadership means we're gonna have a much
bigger impact the lab is going to be the
hub of the information the treating
provider will always be the treating
provider but other people involved are
going to be care coordination at a
health plan maybe pharmacists at a
hospital or an outpatient the quality
care team and our hospitals or our other
institutions that's really where lab and
lab 2.0 kind of leadership is going to
be critical because that's going to
require the lab leaders to start
interacting much more closely with the
other care leaders and to be an equal
clinical colleague going forward I'd
like you to really think about that we
have to be equal clinical colleagues to
our providers managers other people that
are at the leadership level in health
care a laboratory
it has to have a seat at the table we
cannot stay in the basement so with that
I hope those examples impress the you
know the lab can have a huge impact on
patient outcome we can we can definitely
contribute to the Triple Aim and help
our institutions and our enterprises and
our clinical colleagues achieve that the
Triple Aim and actually we can do all
three we can have better quality we can
have better access and and we can lower
the cost of care in America and and we
don't have to compromise on one or two
of those to achieve the other all three
of the Triple Aim actually are
achievable but it's gonna require a big
coordinated effort and the lab should be
an integral part of that a little plug I
guess for any of you who might be
interested in looking a little bit more
of this the clinical lab 2.0 is really
an initiative that came out of what we
call project Santa Fe a number of
laboratories got together and and really
is a coalition of laboratory leaders who
believe that the lab can do more and
should do more and in our institutions
it will do more and so we're really
trying to push that movement and this
website I've listed here
there's demonstration projects of other
of those institutions in addition to
ours
there's workshops we put on to get
people thinking in this direction from
the laboratory and you know pushing the
public publish some of this is really
going to be critical it's going to take
way more than talking about it at
national conferences we really have to
publish and publish the outcomes and the
financial impact and the quality impact
access impact that laboratories can have
on the healthcare enterprise
so with that I'll I'll wrap it up if
there's any questions I'd be happy to
address them by email
thank you dr. Crossy for that
informative presentation I would also
like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational webcast possible as
a final reminder our speaker will follow
up with any questions you've submitted
via email that's all for now thank you
for joining us we'll see you next time
goodbye